at some point you have to start asking whether
it's incompetence or malice with the Andrew
Yang stuff. CNBC during a segment on the
program squawk box about the 2020 democratic
presidential primary put up pictures of some
other Asian guy whose last name also happens
to be yang instead of a picture of the actual
candidate Andrew Yang. They also put up a
picture of a blonde Senator Kirsten Gillibrand
instead of the actual presidential candidate
tool. See Gabbert whose hair is very, very
far from blonde to hard to imagine how the
mistake was made. Let's first take a look
at the video introduced by CNBCs Joe Kerner
Kernan, who has previously attacked me on
Twitter as a communist or socialist or something.
Afterwards, I will describe what we see in
the video. The pictures in question during
this short clip are on the right of your screen.
If you are listening and not watching, I will
describe it to you momentarily. Yeah. 2020
candidates and announced our fourth quarter
fundraising halls for 2019 president Trump's
in the lead with Sanders coming up.
Second, several candidates announcing their
best halls of the campaign cycle. Join us
now for a look at the impact the latest, uh,
numbers have on the 2020 race. Okay, so now
let's look at a still still image. As you
can see above yang, it is a picture of an
Asian male whose last name is yang, but it
is not Andrew Young, the presidential candidate.
It is reportedly Jeff Yang, the founder of
a company called the red point ventures. Then
above tool. See Gavin's name. It's a picture
of New York Senator Kirsten Gillibrand. Now
Jill, LeBron did actually run for the democratic
nomination this cycle. I almost forgot about
that. It feels like it was years ago, but
it was this cycle she dropped out. Jeff Yang,
to my knowledge, was never a candidate for
the democratic nomination. You might also
remember that MSNBC previously named Andrew
Yang, John Yang in the lower third that said,
John Yang crowd serves on 2020 trail.
So I want to hear from you. Is this in competence
or is it malice? I've previously mentioned
on the show Hanlon's razor. Hanlon's razor
is a quote attributed to Robert J Hanlon of
Scranton, Pennsylvania, Scranton, a a a center
of philosophy and Proverbs for sure. Uh, Hanlon's
razor says, w never attribute to malice that
which is adequately explained by stupidity.
I would actually start to think that this
is malice other than like what the hell is
the point? I mean, I hate to break it to the
yang gangers and the tool. See people, I had
both of them yesterday on Twitter telling
me that yang will be the president of the
United States. That tool C will be president.
Neither is going to even be the nominee. I
don't know like why CNBC needs to do this
to keep them down. So I'm leaning towards
incompetence of some kind.
But I do want to hear from you. I, I think
really if you say is it malice or incompetence,
I think it's indifference to yang specifically
more so than to tool C. CNBC has since apologized.
Producers say it was merely an accident. Squawk
alley host John Fort explained quote. Now
unfortunately on this network we accidentally
aired the wrong photos for both Andrew Yang
and tool C Gabard and we apologize for that
mistake. So let me know what you think. What
is the most likely scenario here? And by the
way, speaking of, because we have a story
here about Andrew Yang and tool C, I want
to point your attention to a a Twitter post
that I made yesterday. I, yesterday I went
to my Twitter followers, all 101,000 of you
and I said, I want to hear from people, I'm
Dee Pacman on Twitter. I said, I want to hear
from people who believe that Andrew Yang or
tool C will ultimately be the nominees.
Okay, what is their path? What States do they
win? How do the numbers add up whether or
not you have an opinion on that, check out
the replies to that post. This was yesterday,
a January 7th that I posted this on Twitter
at D Pacman. Look through the responses and
see what you think about the arguments being
made by the yang gangers and the uh, the,
the tool sees the Tulsa, I don't know what
to call them, the Tulsi followers. See if
the arguments resonate with you, but also
if you are someone in that camp, if you believe
that Andrew Yang is going to be the nominee,
if you believe that tool, see Gabbert is going
to be the nominee. Find my post on Twitter
from yesterday about this and respond to me
and tell me what their path is. I am interested
in, I may even do an upcoming segment saying,
here is how the yang gangers and the tool
sees, see their respective candidates having
a path to the nomination.
I think it could be interesting insight into
their minds and their thought process.